but I'm really interested in seeing in
Minneapolis is the level of enthusiasm
of delegates up until last week you had
mostly they were galvanized by an
anti-obama faction the Republicans were
rallying around being against Barack
Obama but not really for McCain the
palin nomination seems to have changed
that there seems to be some early
indications that the rank-and-file
delegates are actually galvanizing
behind the ticket and actually in
support of McCain which I want to see
how that plays out this week is the
delegates get to know Sarah Palin but it
seems to a band something that rarely
happens in which a VP pick actually
changes the dynamics of the campaign in
fact I've actually just this week made
100 olivet the McCain would win which
I've been involved in campaigns long
enough to know that that goes
counterintuitive to everything we think
about the electorate right now the
Democrats have so many advantages right
now but I also know from campaigns the
campaign's do matter what we've had in
the last several weeks is McCain is
dictating the terms of the campaign the
obama camp has to react to McCain and
they're having to reorganize their plans
now with the sarah palin pick that's a
dangerous place to be in the campaign
and as long as mccain can dominate the
terms of the debate vote against the
herd i think will win